et
maintenant on passe à nos invités
polémique
[Musique]
alors en 2001 jean jacques bourdin re
bonsoir
quand vous êtes reporter de guerre
auteur d'une dizaine de livres dont
chienne de guerre prix albert londres en
2000 après l'afghanistan la tchétchénie
l'irak la syrie vous portez pour la
première fois votre regard sur
l'hexagone et ça donne dans quelle
france convie en poche chez plurielles
le 9 octobre jean jacques bourdin vous
êtes le mari dame
[Musique]
c'est vraiment être la première oui bien
solidaire on ne lâchera pas
tu dois ranchi [ __ ] aig est en forme
depuis le 14 ans voilà alors rmc bfmtv
en revanche ça fait 16 ans et vous
présenter tous les matins dans bourdin
direct du lundi au vendredi de 6h à 10h
vous êtes rencontrés en 2004 devant les
caméras and à l'époque vous viviez en
russie vous étiez en france pour la
sortie de lendemain de guerre et peut
être attaché de presse vous conseille de
faire bourdin ce n'est pas qui c'était
voilà mon avis aux clients qui excuse et
vous jean-jacques nous n'avions aucune
envie de la recevoir vous êtes battus
contre votre équipe à l'époque vous
dites que l'afghanistan l'irak ne s'est
pas vente c'est clair d'asie centrale ça
fait ch et ou non non surtout faut dire
une chose assez qui vous avait déjà
interviewé une fois sur rmc et vous
aviez trouvé qu'elle était sèche j'avais
dit elle a du caractère alain ducasse ça
m'avait intrigué par les reptiles
caractère vous propose de l'interviewer
vous dit ouh là là
j'ai dit bon
l'afghanistan encore l'afghanistan mois
la marche mais oui c'est vrai j'avais
fait beau et donc sincèrement et
honnêtement l'interview mieux parce que
louis hachette presse dit non non elle
est formée à la radio 1 il n'y avait pas
de caméra vous dit anne nivat vous dites
il m'a alpaguer c'est à dire que bourdin
ne séduit pas ils alpague
à hilla le pag anne nivat et je lui
demande son numéro de téléphone
rien d'original très franchement ça n'a
rien changé c'est la même chose dans ce
bas vous le voir chez bwin bourdin vous
courent après avec vous repartez quant à
moscou vous repartez quand moscou est
est-ce qu'on peut se voir avant votre
nom de derry n'ai pas déjeuné ensemble
elle n'a pas dit non mais non mais c'est
magnifique quand ça nous arrive ça bah
oui c'est pas du fils peu
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça ressemble à une comédie romantique
mais dans les bureaux de rmc si on
connaît rmc honnêtement c'est moins
drôle que un c'est certain je savais
qu'il ya derrière le fumeur je sais pas
qui mêle buzzer
alors comme dans la vraie vie il nous
fait aussi ses questions piège là à ces
questions pièges moi je trouve qu'il ya
pas de questions qui n'ont alors y'a
quand même il ya un très grand serviteur
5e tettey hausse alors je suis désolé la
ja c'est par pièce moi je trouve que
tout le monde doit tout assumer après
coup le problème c'est que dans les
médias on joue la comédie on fait de la
com etc etc ce qu'il faut dire quand
même c'est que la question à sarkozy sur
les sunnites et les chiites c'est une
question à vous
voilà je lui souffre des questions le
souffle et les questions et pas les
pires jean jacques lasserre
comme il ya toujours une fin toujours au
jour alors la pire question qui vous est
posée est ce que c'est tu veux m'épouser
il m'a demandé c'est même pas d'ailleurs
comment
commence à vous et à
vous
la voulez être sûr votre fils
c'est en fait à quoi bon alors je suis
sûr que si vous avez le malheur de ne
pas répondre à l'une de ces questions du
genre on mange quoi ce soir par exemple
l'excellent qui fait la cuisine mais
parce que sinon il serait capable
lui que se demande comment en tous les
cas je pense effectivement qu'une femme
qui n'aurait pas vécu la guerre les
bombardements rue du mal à supporter
pour jacques bourdin
alors en même temps vous vous défendez
super bien je suis obligé de défendre et
on regarde
pas bonjour oui bonjour oui spécialiste
de la russie grand reporter
anne qui est ma femme je dis toujours
pas ce que tu sais on sait jamais après
il ya des mauvaises langues qui pourrait
dire que
directes 16 direct d'appétit pour pas
lui faire perdre deux tours il a pas
perdu de temps là c'était pour moi annie
wable la main sur reporter de guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en tant que reporter de guerre vous
pensez quoi des journalistes qui
préfèrent rester bien au chaud dans un
studio a interviewé des politiques ben
écoutez je ne sais pas j'en connais pas
trop
non bien je pense qu'il faut de tout
pour faire du journalisme et nous avons
une façon de travailler très différentes
mais en face complète il faut c'est vrai
que le plus gros risque de bourdin sait
recevoir un postillon d'un invité dans
la vie ça peut arriver alors en faire
une interview les amours
[Musique]
allez on se lave à quelle heure le matin
4 heures 15 au [ __ ] quel est son
parfum préféré bon j'arrête non mais moi
je n'ai pas pas pour autant pas de
parfum mettez pas de parfum mais selon
jacky rares maçons les reporter de
guerre ne met pas parfait non je ne suis
pas standard reporter de guerre je parle
que en mon nom pour vous vidéo un peu d
eau comme un match en mangeant les
montagnes c'est vrai qu'on passe d'être
humaines fortes charges et amis quelle
façon sont bloqués
[Applaudissements]
il laisse aller
ma chanson préférée ces chefs
n'étaient pas tous n'étaient pas tous à
jeff kelly mission qu'il voudrait
présenter
c'est une émission qui n'existe plus
ouais laquelle droit de réponse aux
plaques ah bah ouais ouais c'est une
très bonne et changera de la maison t'as
pas de réponse
[Applaudissements]
jean jacques cottel lui matelly le
tournage va se connaît ancien de guerre
et c'est un livre formidable en
tchétchénie qui se passe en kick and
kelly sont complexes physiques se
gêneront c'est tout petit complexe que
qui est pas du tout c'est quoi ces camps
les embarquer ça se voit pas il bosse à
six acteurs zac ne sont pas graves
sérieuses raisons jean-jacques est la
date anniversaire de votre rencontre
le 4 octobre 2004
[Applaudissements]
trois jours de deuil national
est ce que vous savez à quel âge il a eu
son premier rapport sexuel sur zac mais
4 octobre
bonnes réponses
finissons plus gros fantasmes
fantasme de jonzac ça n'est pas
comptable dans cette émission quand les
gens ne répondent pas ils sont pixelisé
pas de problème vous l'êtes pixelisé
pourvoira alors jean jacques qu'est ce
qui fut fait peur à pas rentrer chez toi
rien
6 6 6 pc quand qu'une guêpe euros d'un
petit peu autour de la table mais c'est
tout et c'est tout ah oui tous là par
les guette à la peur ne
[Rires]
voulait arrêter d'être pixelisé ou les
engrais pitch est riche passé quand même
pas cool
[Musique]
oh
jean-jacques j'ai vues macro corrèze
mercredi je les ai vus aurillac
2 le bordel ils feraient mieux d'aller
regarder
parce qu'il y en a qui on les qualifie
mais je sais bien mais c'est pas loin de
dire non mais par la
manière forcée ça vous choque jean
jacques bourdin le franc parler du
président
ce qui me choque c'est que il sait qu'il
y a les manifestants pas très loin et
donc ils ne résident pas tout de même à
dire mais il a dit ce qu'il pensait il
le pense sincèrement
ça me choque pas particulièrement
ça surprend aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le
politiquement correct est telle que je
ne peux plus rien des ces biens ne peut
plus rien dire il faut parler comme
françois hollande maintenant pour pas
être emmerdés qua non maintenant
maintenant c'est choquant quand on sait
qu'il y a dehors des hommes qui ont plus
de 50 ans et qui ne pourront pas aller
travailler à 145 kilomètres de chez eux
pourquoi et pourquoi parce que à 50 ans
où 52 ans il faut se former surtout
quand on travaille dans une entreprise
qui fait dans l'emboutissage
aller travailler dans une fonderie a 52
ans c'est un peu difficile quand on a
une maison une famille à deux heures de
route c'est un peu difficile mais mon
père il a déménagé toute sa vie pour
avoir du travail mais ils aller là où
est il travaille le père de ramzi
l'habitat haut rhin mais je rangeais sur
la base il y avait du travail en france
est par nature et sur la mobilité je ne
peux pas attendre que le travail bien à
vous non mais je suis non mais là je
suis complètement d'accord c'est pour ça
que je dis que sur le fond il a raison
mais sur la forme l'endroit le lieu
alors qu'il sait qu'il ya des
manifestants dehors là c'est un peu plus
gênant que ça fasse le buzz que ça fait
ça me paraît pas tout non pas du fond on
parle d'économie et c'est la raison pour
laquelle plus personne ne croit en les
journalistes c'est la raison pour
laquelle le grand public dit les
journalistes sont des menteurs parce
qu'on est trop artificielle parce qu'on
fait trop attention aux choses qui sont
justement superficiel le journalistique
mans correct on en crève on en crève ça
vous choque vous que tout le monde ses
nerfs parce qu'il a dit ça moi
robert roy taton et les enfants sont
partis
[Rires]
les chaînes de nouvelles en continu il
faut ouvrir la bête la belle sarah doc
moi je suis pour les gaffes ce que je
trouve qu' axa qui fait avancer le
schmilblick sinon tout le monde se
surveille pirelli qui arrivent en france
in gaza me robert ses revenus
non non je parle en général j'aime rica
j'aime les forêts d'appeler ça y est
mais quelqu'un qui dise qu'ils pensent
et oui sinon on s'en va où granby on l'a
perdu la vie sur la ville à sion on l'a
perdu j'étais sûr au tir tout n'est
[Applaudissements]
qu'un avis sur la question il n'a pas
quarante ans quand on parle parle comme
ça bon c'est vrai qui admet il ya les
gens juste derrière et puis doit savoir
qui a la caméra aussi mais j'ai il a
même pas 40 ans mais qu'on parle comme
ça fabrice pareil même même quand tu
présenter un film coliques printemps qui
fait attention à tout est mauvaise et
que le moindre truc peut te [ __ ] en
l'air donc c'est ça devient très
compliqué
anaïs ça ne choque pas non plus sa
bouche mais bon ça nous choque pas ici
ce qui est déjà très bien voilà
maintenant ah ben on va parler de votre
lille juste après l'éviction de blacko
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
anne nivat est une reporter de guerre
qui va là où les autres ne vont pas
après l'irak l'afghanistan la
tchétchénie elle a donc décidé de
visiter laval evreux et montluçon dans
le temps on appelait ça la province
aujourd'hui on parle de la france
périphérique tandis que paris et les
grandes villes profitent de la
mondialisation dans le reste du pays les
temps sont durs
je travaille pour la république
française punit clivage droite-gauche
désormais c'est france d'en-haut france
d'en bas le second tour macro le pen
exprimait parfaitement ce nouveau visage
de la france ce qui les opposait c'était
leur vision de la mondialisation parce
que vous portez c'est l'esprit des fêtes
c'est expliquer à nos concitoyens c'est
trop dur la mondialisation pour nous
c'est trop dur l'europe le nouveau
président incarne la france d'en haut et
celle des grandes villes depuis cent
mille habitants qui ne représente que 40
% de la population mais qui produisent
deux tiers de la richesse du pays donc
son discours une attente à versailles
matheron avait d'ailleurs bien expliqué
que les petites villes de province ce ne
serait pas sa priorité je suis pour que
partout lorsqu'il ya des métropoles qui
réussissent lorsqu'il ya ces grandes
cités qui triomphent dans la
mondialisation on puisse les aider à
aller plus loin
comme le dit mélenchon jeu maquereau et
le président des riches la preuve à
paris l'immobilier et à 10000 euros le
mètre carré et macro obtenu 90 % des
voix au second tour
pendant ce temps là la france d'en bas
s'inquiète mais reste utilisé jaune
entre le pen qui voulait sortir de
l'euro et mélenchon qui ne parlent
jamais de l'immigration où vient des
candidats populistes nature rassembler
l'électorat populaire mais qui sait
l'amérique est du trump les bris nick
ont choisi briques site alors peut-être
qu'en 2022 la france d'en bas enverra
son candidat et qu'ils
étaient venus aux échos mise en image de
julien gracq gérois qu'elle vive a
applaudi qui veut dire qu'elle n'a rien
à redire sur le sujet ça nous rassure
j'étais avec stéphane bakhos qui sait
pas s'il s'en souvient en hypokhâgne
pour ça je connais en bout il était pas
de fille géniale franchement la loi
relative à votre enquête dans quelle
france on vit est disponible à partir du
9 octobre en poche aux éditions curial
le déclarer quand on parle de la france
et les français cela a plus de résonance
que quand on parle des irakiens des jaf
quand c'est vrai que j'ai passé un
certain nombre d'années à risquer ma vie
pour raconter la vie des autres à mes
compatriotes
il n'avait pas forcément envie qu'on
leur a non mais c'est en même temps se
trouve c'est humain c'est très difficile
d'entendre parler toutes ces guerres qui
sont en dehors de notre monde mais il
faut quand même se rend compte qu'en
dehors de la bulle de confort dans
laquelle nous vivons tous plus ou moins
bien certes mais c'est quand même bill
de confort dans le sens où il n'y a pas
de guerre eh bien ça bouillonne ça
bouillonne et moi je pense je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des gens qui
aillent dans le bouillon pour pouvoir
justement le racontez moi je fais rien
d'autre je suis pas la seule on est
quand même quelques-uns alors vous avez
donc décidé de tourner votre regard donc
sur l'hexagone en appliquant les mêmes
méthodes que pour découvrir les pays en
guerre elle est intéressée à la france
service enfance
et
matt
si les français se plaignent parfois
craquer
or celle ci est sous l'influencé de jean
jacques c'est à dire que moi avec
jean-jacques j'entends parler de la
france tous les jours il a tous les
jours les français au téléphone et moi
la même celui il faut le dire quand même
qu'il a inventé ça ils les écoutent où
les mêmes achats de regret dans la voix
oui voilà et moi je fais la même chose
mais généralement je le fais loin à
l'étranger dans des pays effectivement
compliqué l'irak l'afghanistan la syrie
la tchétchénie et mais je fais la même
chose et là j'ai décidé de le faire en
france ah ouais vous êtes intéressé à
l'emploi l'emploi à montluçon au niveau
du demandeur à laval du côté du patron
voilà ensuite le malaise des jeunes à
evreux points donc c'est des grands
problèmes dans des villes de 50000
habitants quant aux rythmes ajaccio où
c'est intéressant c'est vrai que
personne ne l'avait fait avant vous faut
avoir le courage souvient encore le
courage courage ne sait pas tirer à les
refouler alors montluçon je ne pense pas
qu'il faille beaucoup de courage je
pense qu'il faut uniquement de la
volonté dark dawn va pas se calmer mais
parce que vous voyez là comme ça très
directive est sûre de moi mais dans mon
métier je suis pas du tout comme ça
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
chose qui m'intéresse c'est rentrer le
plus possible avec le plus de discrétion
possible dans la vie des gens pour
qu'ils me la raconte et que je puisse la
partager la transmettre nous allons
changer les traités le sentiment de
déclassement à laon oui j'ai été faire
une tournée avec un facteur et ses élans
lens est au nord de paris c'est une
magnifique villa de hollywood est une
ville basse avec une cathédrale de laon
absolument sublime vous avez traité de
l'insécurité à lons le saunier à lons le
saunier petit relent jeudi réplique à
menton dans son sillage où il n'y a pas
du tout d'insécurité 1 dans leur herti
stick les gens y croient intéresse vous
savez bien c'est qu'on n'a pas un
statisme l'usiné gens de talent là tout
le monde se sent en insécurité à lons le
saunier comme ailleurs donc une fois de
plus je détruire les stéréotypes et puis
alors on essaye l'identité ajaccio ouais
parce que j'aime la complication et que
l'identité je pouvais la traiter dans
plein de villes françaises mais ajaccio
j'ai rajouté une strate c'est à dire que
il ya l'identité française d' identité
arabe maghrébine des quartiers d'ajaccio
comme plein d'autres quartiers de france
et l'identité corse un troisième strate
donc là c'était absolument jamais
d'avoir les trois et de raconter la
réalité de ce que vous racontez
d'alleurs formidablement bien dans votre
film qui est une comédie et ça je trouve
ça génial c'est qu'il faut passer
peut-être par la comédie par le rire
pour pouvoir dire des choses que moi
malheureusement ce j'en suis encore à
essayer de raconter dans le réel mais je
pense qu'il faut les deux mais tout ça
c'est à cause du fait que les médias
prennent tout par les petites phrases et
qu'on peut plus rien dire avant donc on
a des comédies où on a des grands
reportages je suis juste à dire qu'on
traite l'actualité aujourd'hui par
l'anecdote ouais le traité l'actualité
sur leur actualité jean-jacques place
par dédain traite l'actualité par
l'anecdote c'est la culture du beurre
exactement and jésus votre bouquin
ça m'a donné envie de quitter le pays
vous comprenez dans ce bouquin justement
il ya de la réalité et dans la réalité
on oublie le côté positif c'est qu'il ya
de la fraternité c'est qu'il y a je
trouve que tous les français que j'ai
rencontrés sont capables de parler d'eux
mêmes et de leur vie qui est pas
forcément une vie folichonne certes mais
il en parle avec de l'humour de l'auto
humour et puis justement les yeux
ouverts moi j'ai pas envie on est dans
un monde de bisounours la conclusion la
morale que vous tirez de votre travail
la morale c'est qu'il faut vivre les
yeux ouverts et qu'il faut pas se
leurrer on est comme on est notre pays
va plus ou moins bien mais
il va en tout cas mieux que les pays
dans lesquels j'ai l'habitude d'aller
qui sont en guerre et c'est parce que
j'ai été dans ces pays en guerre et que
j'en suis revenue vivante c'est une
chance je suis revenu dans mon pays en
france où j'ai finalement quand même
beaucoup de chance de vivre que j'ai eu
envie de raconter comment vivaient dans
ce pays la
nuit va dans quelle france on vit c'est
publié en poche chez plurielles
et maintenant on passe à la question
sous serment
[Musique]
et
m
jean jacques bourdin oui les yeux dans
les rires les slaouis les yeux dans les
yeux jurés vous que vous n'avez jamais
désuni avec un homme politique
déjeuner avec un homme politique ça
m'est arrivé peut-être une fois ouais
mais il était plus en fonction mais
c'était quand louis borloo
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus